finally the rock has come back
to los angeles to determine who is
the people's champion amongst the
corridor crew now you may have seen our
other celebrity impersonator olympics
but none of them
are gonna compare to this one because
the rock is
the hardest hitting hardest working man
ever to be seen on the face of the
planet
can we live up to that no but we're
gonna try we have a whole
slate of wonderful games to find not
only
who can claim the title as the most
electrifying man in entertainment but
the people's
champion
i'm suave i'm cool 90s rock the best
rock
oh yeah this thing yeah it just stays
there hey what's up i'm the only person
here who's actually
met the rock
[Music]
just watching them on tv or in a movie
it's not gonna teach you much about this
guy's personality
so this is the hand he shook here so
with this hand i'll perform all my feats
today to channel
every ounce of his energy these jabronis
come in here and think that they got
what it takes
i'm just here to say as hobbs they don't
stand a chance i am the animated version
of dwayne johnson known as maui bust all
this demigod power on these
challengers you're gonna really channel
my inner hawaiian and inner maui
clearly i'm gonna win because i am the
rock on his happiest day
wedding day rock um i'm gonna make you
the rock on his worst day his divorce
oh god no we don't talk we don't talk
about that what's up people
i'm kevin hart from jumanji 2. i'm going
to win i'm going to win and i'm going to
win the people's champ is here
i'm the rock's personal chef some say
the busiest man in hollywood i'm here to
make sure that this isn't just a big
johnson competition
and that everyone's egos stay the
perfect temperature smell
what the rock is cooking now the true
rock would know
exactly what ingredients are in his
favorite meal so i have all the
constituent ingredients for a
philadelphia cream cheese roll i'm going
to give them a whiff of each ingredient
so if they guess an ingredient right
they get a point if they guess the whole
recipe right they get five points
let's go i got a garden i smell herbs
all day i'm the rock
and these are the pebbles i'm the rock
i'm the rock i'm looking at the rock now
you're a loose amalgamation of pebbles
okay
so then we'll tally up all the
ingredients that they've written and the
two rocks with the least amount correct
they're cancelled they could be part of
it kevin kevin
oh we're good we're good you all get one
lifeline you all get one
taste test at the end right okay
[Music]
i know that okay taste test
got it what is it still from my nose
there [ __ ] taste test oh yes
okay oh taste test
we're moving on to i'd say the most
important ingredient of this whole
recipe it's the signature ingredient i
know what it is
got it hmm what a okay
wait wait give me a little so now that
all the contestants have smelled the
ingredients of choice
we're going to go through and see who
knows the rock's favorite recipe
so in first place is dwayne i'll see you
in the finals like
what else can i say in second place is
dwayne
maui son let's go tying in third place
with three points each
is dwayne and duane back there
no no he got sushi we have a crazy turn
of events let me present something to
you
verify everything wes wrote sushi which
is technically half of the real
wrestling i wrote sushi twice
too recipe that's like calling shrimp
alfredo
pasta that's not a recipe he got a lot
closer than some of these dwains
we are going to award him half of the
final point so two and a half points
on top of his one actually brings him up
into the third place
rung that means that jordan is
eliminated and we now have to have a
tiebreaker between sam and jake will you
clearly have me confused with somebody
who actually gives a crap
these two rocks are gonna be talking
smack to each other the one the audience
likes best
moves on i'll say a few things jake are
you writing down insults
uh just a few some people uh might not
be happy with what i say here
and smackdown sam
i spoke with the state of hawaii the
other day they called me up
they said he's been wearing hawaiian
shirts they redesigned them all they now
have storms
and lightning and sinking ships on them
because
of you see it's a lot of big talk from a
big man
i see what you do there though i see
your hand i see what you have written
down on it some notes
well i can see it all up and down your
arm there too you must be a forgetful
guy but buried up in there somewhere on
your kids birthdays too
gotta respond you know sam i'm glad you
took the opportunity to talk about my
children
i called your wife i got her number i
said sarah what's going on
we talked on and on and she said i can't
believe it
sam he's the reason all my kids are ugly
moving on to the next round is dwayne
johnson mr jake watson
sam
[Laughter]
so dwayne the rock johnson is an action
star the action star
and what action stars do they find
themselves in precarious cliffhanging
situations
we're gonna have all four of our
remaining contestants hanging on this
ledge the first one to drop down is out
hey wes how much do you weigh like 20 30
pounds
is gonna win no matter what because it's
just like 30 pounds what are you talking
about
yeah right here in my rocks it doesn't
work i don't think it works like that
i'm actually going to leave on the extra
weight yeah because i know i'm gonna win
oh yeah i got this pinewood derby track
right my way but it's cool that's
another video
go to node to see that it's gonna be
crazy ready
that's it
intensive endurance
oh i win oh sweet all right
with the extra weight too hey you're
moving on you're moving on
you're moving on don't have the shoulder
for it good luck to the rest of the
duanes
no dwayne the rock johnson challenge
would be complete without the scorpion
king
in this famous scene the scorpion king
is buried alive up to his neck
and these bugs are trying to eat him the
only way he can survive is to eat them
back
each contestant will earn one point per
each bug they can eat and the one with
the most bugs
wins time limit here is 45 seconds now
wes
will have that amount of time to catch
as many as he possibly can
who's counting two
six seven wait did he get that one
right there
what's the time seconds
six seconds five four three
he got it i counted 14 bucks
jake beat west by two bugs 12 bugs
12 of them i'll put them out like the
official count is 13 bucks
wes is out wait a second why am i
shaking your hand no
no my my hand was like this this is not
a shaken
i was like this is completely wesley
good luck wesley
man so for our last challenge we are
headed to the islands of te fiti
i see what's happening yeah each
contestant is going to have
20 minutes to memorize and then perform
perhaps the rock's most famous
song you're welcome have you ever heard
the song before i've seen the movie once
by random chance i have a very specific
way of memorizing things
so i'm gonna i'm gonna use that i see
what's happening here
clint's face to face with greatness and
it's strange he doesn't even know how he
feels
jake has kids all right i'm the rock
from his happiest day and this is a very
happy song
look clint's a smart guy he could get
through this
but i've been preparing for this moment
the entirety of my eldest daughter's
life four years
i've been watching this movie your 20
minutes to memorize starts now
get that thing up on youtube where's my
where's my pen
i'll work in the heat it makes me work
harder hey
so there's a couple lines i'm not 100
sure on a couple words actually it's
just a few words but we're just doing
the end so i'm just going to focus on
that for now
we got 12 minutes left clint kind of
scared me he didn't even have headphones
on him
so that tells you that ready
well come to think of it kid honestly i
could go on and on
i could explain every natural phenomenon
the sky the grass the ground oh that was
maui just messing around i could live
near i buried his guts sprouted a tree
now you got coconuts what's the lesson
what is the take away don't
mess with maui when he's on the
breakaway and the tapestry here in my
skin
is a map of the victories i win look at
me man i make everything happen look at
this minute need my weed
dude you already freaking know it what
can i say
except you're welcome i missed doing the
wrong job he doesn't do
anything half ass he's the entertainment
guy of the world so
nailing the lyrics and the melody is one
thing but you gotta
you gotta perform this thing and there's
this last section of the rap
where he's just like really confident
and talking about his wins and victories
and his tattoos and like i'm really
expecting to hear some gusto during that
point
this is the hard one look at that mini
email we just did betty tapping
i think he says minnie he says the knee
twice on minnie minnie maui just tippity
tapping
clint at about five minutes asked if
we're allowed to have the lyrics
so that's where we are with who i think
is gonna win
five four three two
i got these lyrics in my head and i'm
gonna let i'm just let it take over i'm
just gonna take over and i'm gonna win
this it's going down like let's do this
before i forget these lyrics
this rap competition is gonna be judged
on two factors who fumbles the least
and style points give you a five second
countdown push play
you ready let's go five four
three two one
kid honestly i can go on and on i can
explain every natural phenomenon from
the tide the grass the ground
oh that was maui just messing around i
killed an eel i buried its guts sprouted
a tree now you got coconuts what's the
lesson what's the takeaway don't mess
with maui when he's on a breakaway
there's tapestry here on my skin is a
map of the victories i win
look where i've been look what i made
happen that was just mountain just
tippity tippity tappin
[Applause]
all right all right i'm happy with that
if i lose i'm happy with that all right
i didn't i am impressed by that
you sent it oh feeling about the bar
whatever happens i respect
always the best man will win
well come to think of it kid honestly i
could go on and on i could explain every
natural phenomenon
the sky the grass the ground oh that was
my way just messing around
i killed o'neal i buried his gut
sprouted a tree now you got coconuts
what's the message what is the takeaway
don't mess with maui when he's on a
breakaway and the tapestry here in my
skin
is a map of the victories i win look at
me man i make everything happen look at
this mini
melody tippity tap tap chat chat
[Music]
he got one lyric wrong but i think he
took that one
dwayne blaine's first off props to you
both thank you that was amazing thank
you
this is kevin i gotta say though i felt
the true spirit from none other
than jake watson
lukon
come here jake it was an honor jake
you you've earned this every step of the
way you were you were a formidable
opponent and you have watched moana so
many times you had those lyrics down
they came from the heart
i barely had to study hey i'm just happy
to stand next to
arnold schwarzenegger right here yeah
and we work out together
and jackie chan right here we work out
together and now that everyone
has a title it's time to reach for the
stars boys so if you guys want to see in
the comments you know
office mr bean we should take on next
this belt has a uh
a w on it for wesley
we're back wes yes if you guys want to
see
more of these videos consider
subscribing and let us know in the
comments below if there's any other
celebrity impersonator challenges you
would like to see from us
next if you liked these games consider
checking out our other channel
node it's where a bunch of jabronis get
together play games have fun and
challenge each other and man we just did
one we made our own pinewood
derby so go on over there and subscribe
and if you're not subscribed here
consider doing so and thanks for
watching